[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAY TSANG: Thank you for
coming to this session.
My name is Ray.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
And one of the
things I love to do
is to bring some of
our best technologies
to developers all over
the world, especially Java
developers, because I've been a
Java developer for a long time.
It's my go-to
language of choice.
And yeah, it's also a great
and vibrant community.
And I'd love to bring
some of the things
that we have to show you.
Another thing I like
to do because of this
is I like to make
sure that we have
really good experiences
for Java developers
to use Google Cloud Platform.
And so I work with
a lot of the teams
internally, like for Cloud
Functions, for App Engine,
for Cloud Run, and
stuff like that,
to make sure that we have a
pretty good, awesome experience
there, as well as the API
services and stuff like that.
And because of that, I also
help introduce and kickstarted
a project called
Spring Cloud GCP.
And it is an idiomatic
approach to help
you to bootstrap your
Spring application
and consume some of the
Google Cloud Services
very idiomatically and easily.
If you have any
questions, any feedback,
please let me know on
Twitter, @saturnism, and/or
if you want to see and
find more information,
you can go to my site,
which is saturnism.me.
And I only have about four
slides for this session.
And we are about 75% through.
And let me show
you the last line.
And thank you for being here.
Just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm just going
to jump into it
and just show you what we
can do from a experience
in developing for
GCP perspective
for a Java developer, OK?
So one of the projects I
mentioned was Spring Cloud GCP.
Now, I just want to
see a show of hands.
How many people here are
Java developers using
Java language, JVM languages?
Yeah, everyone.
Good, you're in the right room.
So am I.
How many of you are using
Spring and Spring Boot?
Majority of you, yeah.
That's what I expect.
And if you haven't checked
this out, please, please do.
We basically wanted to make sure
that from a Spring developer
perspective, you can use some
of the Spring abstractions
and Spring layers that
you're accustomed to
and be able to use some
of our APIs and services.
Now, the reason for
it is a couple fold.
Number one is that it's going
to be a lot easier for you
to get started, right?
So you know your framework.
You know how to
use those things.
And you can just change
out some implementations,
add some starters, add
some other configuration.
And you're right into the
Google Cloud Services.
The other part of it is
that if you have an existing
application that
you want to migrate,
there are some
different approaches.
And one of them
is maybe that you
want to just migrate the VM.
So you put a VM
into Google Cloud.
And now, you're still using the
traditional databases and stuff
like that.
But if you want to change
and gain some velocity
in being able to adopt
some of the services,
you have two choices.
You either use the API,
which, then, you are tightly
coupled to the API itself.
Or you have some kind
of abstraction layer
that you can be a little bit
more portable so that you know
if you want to change out the
implementation in the future,
you also can, right?
So check this project out.
So we have integration for,
like, Spinner and Datastore
with Spring data.
So you can use basic ORM
and data repositories
to access data.
We have logging and
tracing integrations
directly into the
Spring framework
as well, and Pub/Sub,
and much, much more, OK?
I'm going to show you some
of these things today.
But most importantly,
I'm going to-- after we
bootstrap in the application,
we're going to containerize it.
We're going to deploy
into Kubernetes.
And we're going to go through
some of the best practices
or things that you have to watch
out for when you are actually
deploying applications into
a Kubernetes environment, OK?
So without further ado,
I'm going to get started.
I have no backup for this.
It's just going to be a straight
shot from nothing to something.
I hope that works.
So it's either going
to be OK, or it's
going to be horribly wrong, OK?
So let's go.
So for this demo, what
I'm going to do is,
you just go to start.spring.io
to bootstrap my new project.
I'm going to use Kotlin
for this, because for Java,
for JVM, you can run
any JVM languages
on Google Cloud, of course.
So with App Engine, you
can do the JVM stuff.
You can do Kotlin, Groovy,
Scala, or just Java language
itself.
I'm going to make a
JAR packaging here.
And we're going to use Java 8.
And of course, in
this bootstrapping,
you can also add
different capabilities
to your application.
Now, the important thing
here that I'm adding here
is the GCP support.
So by adding this, we're going
to pull in some of the auto
configurations into my project.
And that's going to
make my application
work with some other
Google Cloud Services, OK?
So I'm going to go
ahead and download this.
And I'm going to unpack
it and open this up
in my IntelliJ
plugin here and IDE.
And we'll see what happens next.
Yeah, and where's my IntelliJ?
That's the-- oh, there it is.
It went to the wrong window.
That's weird.
OK, so let me just synchronize
this project a little bit,
just making sure that this is
actually the application we
just created, OK?
And let me just go ahead and go
to the presentation mode too.
So I think I can enter
presentation mode.
So we can hopefully see
all the code a lot easier.
So we have a application here
that has nothing, of course.
It's going to start up
and listen on port 8080.
And that's pretty much it.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is to add some
capability to store data.
Now, we have, of course,
many different ways for you
to store data.
We have Cloud SQL for you to do
RDBMS with MySQL or Postgres.
We have Cloud Spanner, which
is a globally distributed
database for RDBMS as well.
Or we can also use Datastore,
which is a no SQL data
store that's document oriented.
You don't need schemas.
You can just say, I need
data stored, and just start
putting data into it.
So for this demo, I'm just going
to use the Datastore stuff,
right?
So the easiest
thing for me to do
is to add the starter
for Cloud Datastore.
So we have a shortcut
here for the dependency.
And what this will
pull in is Spring Data
and a few other
components and also add
the Datastore abstraction
layer on top of this.
What that means is
that you can actually
go ahead and create a new POJO.
And you can annotate
it, just like you
do with a traditional
database with JPA.
It's going to be
very similar here.
So what I'm going to
do is just to create
a new class here called Person.
I'm using Kotlin here.
So rather than using all
the getters and setters,
I can just create
a data class here.
And it's going to
have two attributes.
It's going to have
an ID, which I'm
going to change
the type to Long,
because in Datastore, we can
auto-generate the ID for you.
And we can go ahead and
just mark it as an ID.
Now, notice how the
ID annotation is here.
This is actually the
regular Spring annotation
for a primary key.
And for the data class
here, we can just
go ahead and make it Entity.
And this Entity is
special for Datastore.
This marks it as a
Datastore entity.
So we know how to map it to
our back-end services, OK?
And then we can use the
Spring Data repositories
for CRED access and
also pagination.
What that means is that I can
create a new interface here.
I can call it PersonRepository.
And I can go ahead and
extend the interface here
called DatastoreRepository,
this one.
And I can just give
it a domain type,
which is going to be
Person, and the ID type,
is going to be Long.
And that's it.
That's all you need to do.
And you can start
using this repository.
Spring and our frameworks
will automatically
implement this
interface for you.
So you can go ahead and
use it to store data.
We're going to go a
little bit further.
We're going to add--
use the Spring Date
Rest annotation here,
which means that we can actually
expose this entire repository
as a RESTful service.
So just like that,
you get CRED access
to the Datastore
entity called Person.
And we should be able to store
data and read data from it, OK?
How many people think
this will just work?
Well, nobody.
Thanks.
So why don't we just
go ahead and run?
And I'll use my touch bar.
There's a little Run button
there, which is really handy.
And we can actually see and
hopefully run this application.
Yeah, and they just
started off in 2.7 seconds.
I don't know.
Whenever my Java application
starts really quickly,
I don't know if
it's going to work.
So we're going to find
out pretty soon, OK?
And I'm going to go ahead
and use my IntelliJ ID here.
I'm going to go ahead
and create a new--
where did it go?
Oh yeah.
Oh no.
The screen is too small.
So I have to scroll
down a little bit.
A new HTTP request.
I'm going to call it test.
So rather than use a curl, I
can actually just go to my IDE
and maybe do something
like this, right?
So get trp, gtr, maybe that one.
So I'm going to go to
my local host, 8080.
And then I'm going to see if
my endpoint is up and running.
And let me go ahead and run it.
And whoo!
It actually works.
So I just hit my
local RESTful service.
I went to the persons endpoint
that was automatically
generated by Spring data.
And I can see that I have no
data entry in the service, OK?
Pretty cool.
So why don't we go ahead and
just post some data into it?
So I'm going to just write
a little snippet here.
I'm going to post to 8080.
I'm going to post it to
the persons endpoint.
And for the data
here, I'm going to--
let's see here.
We have a field called name.
And I'm going to
say Ray in here.
That's my name, by the way.
So let's go ahead
and run this post.
And we will see what happens.
So I'm posting to this
service that I just
created in about three minutes.
And we can already
see it saved the data.
And we also got a primary
URL here with a primary key
that we can call.
So we can just go ahead and
say, well, let's go ahead
and get this as well and
see what is the data inside.
And we can see the
data record here.
And of course, if I
go back to persons,
I should be able to see,
now we have one entry.
Now, notice, also, we
have pagination here.
So that's really, really handy.
Now, if I want to go back to
the console, what I can do
is to go to the
Datastore console
here within my projects.
So I'm going to go find
Datastore, because some people
might say, wait a second.
Is that real?
Did that just happen?
The only way I can prove this
to you that this actually works
is, now, you can actually
see that we actually
have a data entry there.
But of course, this data
entry could have been there
this whole time.
You would never know.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go back to my application.
I'm going to do--
just bootstrap a little bit
more functionality here, OK?
So I'm going to go ahead
and create a hello world
controller here.
Let me just make sure.
Yeah, I'm going to say hello.
And it's going to be
a risk controller.
And I'm going to map a
URL here called /hello.
I'm going to pass in the
name here with name string.
I'm going to log in.
I'm going to return hello back
to whoever said hello to me.
And I'm just going to go
ahead and use private val here
to inject the personRepository
that I just created now.
And what I'm going to do is, in
addition to saying hello back,
I'm going to use
the personRepository
and save the data
back into this.
So I'm going to say
name is equal to name.
And it's something
like that, OK?
And hopefully, that
will just work.
Oh, but wait-- to simulate
that, we have multiple services
to code each other,
because you usually
don't have just one service.
I don't have time to
create two of them today.
But what I'm going to do is to
just simulate this whole thing
by making another
endpoint that's
going to call a few names here.
I'm going to call Mike, who is
the TO on the Spring Cloud GCP
project; Mindy, who is
one of my colleagues
that I first worked with
when I joined Cloud; Jisha,
who is also awesome, and
she contributed a lot
to this project.
I'm going to say hello
to each of the names.
I'm going to use the
restTemplate client
to make a call to
myself to say hello
so we can simulate calling
another service, right?
Just 'cause I don't have
time to write two of them.
And so to do this, I need
to go ahead and, of course,
go ahead and just make sure
we have a RestTemplate Bean
that we can bootstrap.
All these are pretty
idiomatic to Spring.
And I need to go ahead and
automatically inject this
into my controller as well.
So I'm going to go ahead and
do a private val rest template
and just inject it here.
So now, I have two
more endpoints.
I have /hello, which
I will save the data.
I'm going to say
hello all, which
will say hello to three people.
And it will save each
of the data as well.
And I'm going to go ahead and
just restart this application.
I hope that's going
to just work as well.
So I'm going to stop and run.
Whoo!
And let me see, just make sure
this is actually rebooting.
Yeah, very good.
And I'm going to go back
to the test HTTP here.
And let's just do a
few more things, OK?
OK, that also started
pretty quickly.
So hopefully, this works.
So I'm going to say hello
to localhost 8080/hello.
I'm going to say name is NEXT.
Let's do that.
And let's run it.
Say hello to NEXT.
And of course, we
get a hello back.
And remember, we
also saved the data.
And just to show you
that this is actually
saving the data
now, we can see this
up on the screen in
the Datastore, right?
And I can also say hello to all.
So rather than saying
hello to just one person,
I'm going to say hello to all.
So it's going to iterate
through and say hello
to three different people.
And if we go back to
the log, we should
be able to see that we say
hello to Mike, Mindy, and Jisha.
And if we go back
to the Datastore,
we should be able to see all
of the people I said hello to,
right?
So it's very rapid that you can
develop your application very
quickly now.
So what's next?
In a microservices
application architecture,
if you do have all of these
services calling each other,
A calls B calls C, you
kind of need some way
to observe and
kind of understand,
what is the call stack
across all of your services?
And to do that, you may
need to add some distributed
tracing capabilities.
And there are a number
of libraries out there
you can use, like OpenTracing,
OpenSenses, and Brave,
and so on, and so on.
In Spring, we have
Spring Cloud Sleuth,
which can actually add
distributed tracing capability
to your app.
Now, regardless of whether
you deploy your application
into a Istio environment, which
can trace things for you--
regardless of
whether you do that
or whether you just deploy it
in plain Kubernetes or VMs,
you always need to
propagate the trace ID.
You always have to do that.
And Spring Cloud Sleuth or
some of these tracing libraries
can capture the trace ID for
you and propagate it for you
automatically.
Now, for our demo,
what we're going to do
is go even a step further by
adding a tracing starter here
that we created for
Spring Cloud GCP.
What this will do is to build
on top of Spring Cloud Sleuth,
which is built on top of Brave.
What this will do is to
automatically capture
the trace IDs.
If not, it's going to
generate one for you.
And it's also going to
automatically propagate
it downstream to the
next service call
when you're using RestTemplate.
And we're also going
to automatically
propagate all the traces
into Stackdriver Trace, OK?
And we just done that
by adding the starter.
We don't have to add any
other additional code.
The only other thing
that I might actually add
is the probability of
a trace to be stored.
By default, we only capture 10%
of the traces or the requests
where we're going
to store the trace.
For the demo, I'm going to
up it to 1.0, which is 100%,
so we can actually
see everything
that's coming through.
Now, in addition to doing
this, what I also want to do
is to log my messages
into Stackdriver as well.
So we have a logging
starter for that.
What this will do is to
allow you to add a log back
configuration fairly easily.
And you can then
bootstrap your application
that will understand how to
log into Stackdriver Logging.
And there's a reason why
I'm doing this, which
I'll show you in a second.
So let me just go
ahead and do this one.
I'm going to use this
template for now.
So what this will do is to
log the message to the console
so I can see it and SD out.
But I'm also going to log it to
Stackdriver as the other API.
So now, we have
two log appenders.
It's going to split
the log message.
And we're going to
simultaneously send it
to both places.
So let me go ahead and
just restart this app
and see if this is
hooked up properly.
And hopefully, we'll get to
see the traces and the log
messages.
And if you've seen so far,
there's not so much code,
because Spring and Spring
Boot, the framework
itself is doing a lot of the
work behind the scenes for you,
OK?
So it's all started.
So let's go ahead and
go back to my test.
And I'm going to
say hello to all.
Now, ideally, what happened here
is that I trigger this request.
The trace ID is generated.
It's propagated downstream
via the REST template
to the next call.
We have three calls.
So all of them are
correlated together.
If I actually go back to the
run, if I look at the log,
now, not only do
we see the names,
if I scroll left
a little bit, we
can confirm that here's
a trace ID that's been
across three different calls.
And each of the calls is
a span that has a span ID.
And they're all being sampled,
meaning that they are all being
stored into Stackdriver Trace.
So what that means is that if
I go here, and go to Trace,
and see the Trace list, I have
this one additional entry that
maybe just came in.
Yeah, there it is.
And we can see that we
call localhost 8080/all.
We can see the three
different REST template calls
to the remote services,
which is myself.
And we can see how long
each of those take.
And furthermore, because
we appended a log,
we sent a log to
Stackdriver Logging
along with a trace
ID and a span ID,
we can actually do this, which
is show you correlated logging.
So because all of
these ID tie up,
I can actually go and see, OK,
what happened in this span?
What kind of error
messages came out of it?
They're all correlated together,
which is really, really useful
if you're actually trying to
debug some of the production
environment issues, OK?
So that's pretty much it
for my service for now.
What do we do next?
Let's go ahead and deploy it
into my Kubernetes cluster
in this case.
Now, we have, of course, many,
many ways to deploy this.
We can deploy this into
App Engine as a JAR
in the new App Engine runtime.
We can deploy this into
Cloud Run as a container.
We can deploy this
into Kubernetes,
whether it has Istio or not.
It doesn't really matter.
So we're just going to take
the long route of, let's
deploy everything
into Kubernetes.
And I'll show you all
the intrinsic details
that we have to
care about when we
are running a Java application
inside of a container.
So what we're going to do
first is to containerize.
And we're going to talk a little
bit here about containerizing--
can I not spell today?
Containerize, there we go.
And then we're going to talk a
little bit about the liveness
checks and readiness checks.
And we need to
talk about, how do
you listen to the graceful
shutdown events that
is a contract with the
Kubernetes runtime,
where in any Docker
environments that you actually
have a restriction
tool, you want to be
able to shut down gracefully.
And then finally, we're to
look at monitoring as well.
How do you export metrics from
this particular application
so that we can see
it from Prometheus
dashboards in this setting?
And if we have time, we're
going to see how we can actually
debug this application
and production
environment in a Kubernetes
environment as well.
So we're going to
get through that,
hopefully, in the
next 30 minutes or so.
So let's get started.
Now, when you're containerizing
this application,
you have to be very careful.
I don't know if anyone
here ran into this issue
where you containerize
the Java application,
you're running your Kubernetes
cluster or some kind
of environment, and then you
get this weird message called
Out Of Memory
killed, OOM killed.
A lot of people run
into this issue.
That is mostly because the
JVM runtime may or may not
understand how much
resource you actually
assigned to your container.
And to take care of
this, you actually
have to understand which
Java version, which
OpenJDK version you're using.
And what type of containerized
support does it actually have?
Because often
enough, what happened
is that the OpenJDK
runtime does not actually
know how much memory is being
assigned to your container.
And the JVM, which has used
up as much memory as possible,
and ultimately, you're just
going to get OOM killed.
And your application will just
be restarting all the time.
So first, we need to go
ahead and containerize
this application.
Now, I can write a Docker file.
I can write a very simple one.
But I actually have a
separate talk in the past,
just for a whole hour, on
how to write a proper Docker
file that will
containerize your Java app.
There is a lot of details
we have to go through.
Now, luckily enough,
we do actually now
have a plugin called jib.
So if you're not using jib
already, please take a look.
This is a Maven
or Gradle plugin.
You can just add it
to your build file.
And from here on out, I can just
use it to build my container.
I don't need to
write a Docker file.
You'll actually follow
some of the best practices.
And you don't even
need Docker installed
on your local machine.
You'll just push
the image directly
to the remote registry.
So I'm going to go ahead and
create a new image here called
gcr.io.
I'm going to add my private
registry on Google Cloud
right now.
So I'm going to use
jcr.io/wise-coyote-827.
And I'm going to push it to
the image name called jib-demo
for now.
And then I'm going to--
remember about the
JDK, we need to be
very careful about what JDK
version that we want to use.
And how do you configure that?
So for me, what I'm
going to do here
is to by using
adopt OpenJDK, which
has one of the newest
versions of OpenJDK 8
that actually has the
containerization support.
You want to use something
that is 8 update 191 or higher
in order for this to work
properly to have less issues.
So I'm going to add
adoptopenjdk and going
to do openjdk8 and use the
slim image here instead.
And that's all I need to do.
And if I need to, here,
I'm going to go open
up the console, the terminal.
And I'm going to go ahead
and compile this app
and turn this into
a container image.
So I'm going to do Maven wrapper
here, compile, and jib:build.
So I first need to
compile my app, of course,
and produce our classes.
And then jib is going to
do something intelligent.
It's going to look at
your Maven build file.
And it's going to figure out
what the dependencies are.
And it's going to
automatically decide
how to layer your Docker layers
so that the dependencies goes
into its own layer, and your
app goes in a separate layer.
What that means is
that when you're
changing an app a little
bit, you're changing a class.
It doesn't have to
rebuild the entire image.
It just rebuilds the
layer and pushes out
for you automatically.
And we already pushed it
to my remote registry.
And this is ready to be used.
I actually hope this
works, because I was also
a little bit too fast.
So I'm going to
do a Docker pull,
because this a remote registry.
So we can pull this down.
And ideally, we should
be able to run it, OK?
So I'm going to docker run -ti
--rm and the name of the image.
And this should just
spin up my application.
And hopefully, everything is OK.
Yeah.
Ooh, that's no good.
No, that's kind of expected.
That's fine.
We'll fix it later.
All right, so the
container runs.
That's good.
Now, you have the option
to put this into Cloud Run.
It should just start up.
Just make sure you have
enough memory for it.
What I'm going to do is to
just write this and deploy this
into Kubernetes and then
continue my development cycle
in the Kubernetes cluster.
The way I'm going
to do it is to--
first, I need to create
a new directory, where
I'm going to store my
deployment manifest.
With Kubernetes,
you do write a lot
of these YAML files
that manifest to define
how you want deploy something.
So I'm going to do
a shortcut here.
I'm going to do a
kubectl run my--
I'm going to call
it demoservice.
And then the image is the
one that I just created.
There we go.
And I'm going to use this
file called --dry-run.
So what this will
do is actually not
running inside of Kubernetes.
But it's going to
just simulate it.
And I'm going to see
what the request is
going to be in the YAML format.
And I'm going to output
it into my k8s directory.
I'm going to call
it deployment.yaml.
So this a very quick way
for us to kind of bootstrap
a deployment file
without having to write
the whole thing manually.
Now, there's one thing
you do have to figure out
here is to-- here without
the beta, beta 1 version--
because you know,
it's actually GA now.
So we have v1.
And you can see how it just
generated the rest of the files
for me, right?
It's pretty cool.
Now, we know that we have
a container that will work
in a containerized environment.
We have to deal with Kubernetes
in the Kubernetes contracts
in terms of how this application
will behave in the lifecycle.
What that means is, when
the application starts,
there's a lightning
strike that might go off.
We need to be able to check
whether the application is
still alive.
If an application is not
responding to the lightning
strike, Kubernetes will have
to restart it and automatically
try to fix this issue.
The other thing that we
have to watch out for
is the readiness check, right?
In Kubernetes, we
have two checks.
Liveness check just
determines whether Kubernetes
needs to kill this instance
and restart it or not.
The readiness check
is the one that
determines whether the traffic
will be falling through
to my container, to my pod.
So we need-- it's ideal
to have both checks, OK?
You definitely should have both.
Now, the readiness check is
really useful in two ways.
One is that your
application could be alive,
but it may not be
ready to serve.
Why?
Because you might need
to warm up the cache.
You have to make sure all the
connections are established,
everything's ready
to go before you
flip the readiness check over
and say, give me some traffic.
The other use case of it is
that when you are shutting down
the application, when Kubernetes
is trying to shut down
your Java application,
it's going
to send you a SIGTERM signal.
It's a termination signal.
And you are supposed
to catch it and then do
a graceful shutdown.
During this whole
process, ideally, you
should turn off
the readiness check
so that you tell Kubernetes,
I got the message.
I'm going to shut down.
Please don't send
me any more traffic.
And you use that
to tell Kubernetes
whether you are going to
receive traffic or not.
And once you have gracefully
shut down and served
all the in-flight requests,
you shut down your application.
And everything's fine.
So we don't have to do
both of them right now.
For the liveness check,
the easiest way to do that
is just by adding a simple
handler here that would just
respond OK all the time, right?
So I'm going to say, am I alive?
And it's going to say "ok."
And I'm going to map
it to maybe /alive.
That's really easily done.
So I just added a
liveness check here.
The other thing that we may want
to add is the readiness check.
The way that I think
it's pretty awesome thing
to do within the
Spring ecosystem
is actually by using
something called the actuator.
So Spring has something
called the Spring
Actuator that will expose a
health checkpoint for you.
So I'm going to go ahead
and add the actuator--
actuator right here.
It's going to expose a /actuator
endpoint with a health endpoint
there that you can
actually plug in.
And you can use
that to kind of flip
yes or no between whether
your application is
ready or not, OK?
And then there are many
different ways for you
to do a graceful shutdown.
The gist here is that you have
to listen for the termination
signal.
In Java, the way you
do it's by listening
to runtime shutdown events.
And then you have a separate
thread that can react to it.
And then that's where
you respond to the--
and shut down your application.
There's actually a really
nice module out there
that can be useful for you.
It's the graceful shutdown
artifact from SBB CH here.
What that is going to do
is to allow you to replace
how you start your application.
So rather than using the Spring
Boot standard application,
I'm going to go ahead and
use Gracefulshutdown--
let me see here-- a
SpringApplication, like that,
and run, and the
DemoserviceAppli
cation::class.java, and then all
the arguments from the command
line.
And that's pretty much it.
And so this will configure--
this particular module
will configure the application
for graceful shutdown.
And of course, you
can do it however
other ways that you want.
But the important
thing here is that you
have something like that, OK?
Now, I'm ready to
redeploy this app again.
I kind of want to
try this one out,
where I'm developing
my application.
I'm still adding
some features to it.
I need to test things out
in your Kubernetes node
or cluster.
But I don't want to do the
jib build all the time.
I don't want to do the
kubectl apply all the time.
One of the really cool
tools that you can use
is called Skaffold.
If you haven't tried it out,
this is what it looks like.
You can create a new
file code skaffold.yaml,
add it to your IDE--
your project here.
And I can bootstrap it
with just some content.
And I can get rid of just
about everything here.
And I'm going to say,
well, in Skaffold,
what it's going to do is
to automatically detect
changes in your source code.
When you modify something, it's
going to do the recompilation,
rebuild your
application for you,
and then deploy it to Kubernetes
in this continuous loop, OK?
So I'm going to
go ahead and just
make sure I have the name of the
image here correctly, jib-demo.
And then with-- oh, sorry.
Yeah, there we go.
And with Skaffold,
I can also just add
what we call the
jibMaven plugin here.
And as you can see,
down here, we actually
automatically detected that
we added the Skaffold file.
And we can actually
configure the application
to run with Skaffold and
Kubernetes just like that.
Now, the reason why
this is happening
is because we have this new
tool called the Cloud Code.
So this is a plugin you can
add to IntelliJ or VS Code.
And by doing this,
you can actually
integrate fully with Skaffold.
And also, we have
other capabilities,
like being able to deploy
this app to App Engine
and many other places as well.
So let's go ahead and just
finish up this configuration.
I think I can also add args.
Because of the time,
I'm going to skip tests.
Don't do this in your own
development environment.
Maybe you do.
But I only do this
for demos, right?
Only, yeah, of course.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
What's that?
So I'm going to go ahead
and run the Skaffold
thing through the IDE.
So it's going to go ahead
and hook up to my Maven here.
And it's going to
rebuild my app and then
kick off the jib build for me.
And then it's going
to automatically
deploy my YAML file from
the KAS directory, OK?
I'm going to check on time.
I've got 20 minutes.
Yeah, so it's doing the build.
Now, the beauty of jib
is that it should only
change in [INAUDIBLE]
layers that's been changed.
So if I haven't done
a lot of changes,
this whole process
should be really quick.
So I have deployed--
I created my container.
And this is actually deployed
into my Kubernetes environment.
And the log that you
are seeing right now
is actually coming
from Kubernetes, OK?
This is actually running
Kubernetes right now.
It's just the log that's being
streamed into my console.
And I can show you
what that looks like.
So for example, if I
go to kubectl get pods,
we should be able to see that
my application is running, OK?
That's good.
That's good news.
I didn't expect that.
Yeah.
So then, what we can
do is to push the--
I'm going to expose the
endpoint so that we can actually
access it, just so we know
that this is all working.
So I'm going to do
the same trick here.
I'm going to expose.
I'm going to expose the
deployment called demoservice.
The port that we are going
to target is port 8080.
We're going to listen on
the port 8080 as well.
I'm going to do a dry run
and output the YAML file.
I'm going to output it
into k8s/service.yaml.
Now, Skaffold will ideally--
I'm pretty sure it will actually
pick this up, yeah, and then
redeploy this file for me.
So anytime you make some
changes in your source tree,
Skaffold will pick
up the new changes
and push it to Kubernetes.
And because of this,
we should actually
have a new service now that's
being provisioned called
demoservice.
Oh, one thing I forgot to do is
to make this same demoservice
so that we actually get an IP.
So let me go in and fix.
So let me go down here.
And for the load balancer
for the type-- uh-oh,
where's the type?
Let me do the type here, type.
I'm going to say--
oh, yeah-- type
is a LoadBalancer.
Let's do that.
And that will get us a external
IP address so we can actually
test it out, OK?
So what have we done so far?
We created a
brand-new application.
We containerized
it, understanding
what JVM version to use.
We added liveness check
and readiness check.
We added graceful shutdown.
And we're now changing
things, now, with scaffold
so that we can test this thing
out in Kubernetes, hopefully,
very quickly.
And now we have added a load
balancer with an external IP.
So I'm just going to wait for
this IP to become available.
Then we should be able to see
this whole thing in Kubernetes.
Not too bad so far, right?
It's OK, yeah?
All right, so the
next part of this
is to actually add the
deployment, modify it
so that we take advantage
of the liveness checks
and the readiness checks,
and a few things that we
have to watch out for
when you want to do
a zero-downtime deployment.
So first thing first
is the livenessProbe.
We already have
this on port 8080.
And we can also ping it
on the path of /alive.
That's where we put it.
And then we have the
readiness probe that
is also right now on port 8080.
And the path is actually
/actuator/health.
Now, one of the annoying things
that you have to be careful of
is that, remember,
we added tracing.
So trace-- tracing at 100%.
So what that means is every
time I get a health check,
I'm going to see a little
dot on my trace list
for the liveness check.
And that's sometimes
not so useful, right?
So we can actually turn that off
in the liveness probe as well.
The way we're going to do it
is by adding the hb header.
Now, because we're using
Sleuth behind the scenes,
it uses what we call
the x-b3 headers.
So we can use the x-b3
header called x-b3-sampled.
And we can turn this value to 0.
Then, you will not get any more
traces for this endpoint that's
coming from the liveness probe.
This is actually really useful.
Otherwise, you're going
to see a lot of traces,
such as the liveness probe,
which may not help you a lot,
at all, right?
So I'm going to go
ahead and save this.
And again, this is going to
kick off the new deployment.
There you go.
And it's going to apply my
changes and so on and so forth.
So yeah, hopefully,
that's all working.
So let's see if the
IP came back on.
So there it is.
So there's 35, 22, whatever.
And I'm going to go
ahead and try it out.
Let's see if that works.
Oh, OK, not bad, yeah.
OK, so we can also
see the actuator
right now, which is in health.
And oh, look.
This is actually down.
This is cool, right?
Because we have the readiness
probe that we configured.
Remember, I changed
the deployment file.
So it's actually doing
a rolling update.
So as it's doing
the rolling update,
it sends a SIGTERM signal
to my existing instance.
And so now, my readiness
probe is being turned down.
And Kubernetes does
take a couple of seconds
to catch up to this status.
So that's why the thing
is still going through.
But eventually, this thing
will go out of service.
And then now, I'm back
to the new instance
of my app with the
new configuration, OK?
Pretty awesome.
Now, all at the
same time, we still
have to log messages and
everything else that's here.
Now, of course, in Kubernetes,
when you deploy something
to Kubernetes, one of
the things you really
have to watch out for,
regardless of whether it's
run in App Engine, or
Kubernetes, please do not write
logs to the file system.
Just please don't do that.
You either do stdout or
you write it to the API.
And in GKE, what you can do is
to output a log as JSON format.
So rather than sending
it via the API,
you can actually do
something like this.
So I'm going to go
ahead and change this.
And I'm going to use JSON
logging instead, log JSON.
So by changing out
the appender, we
are now able to log
things into JSON messages.
And Stackdriver
has the agent that
can automatically parse it.
And you get the same benefits
of getting the log levels,
and the trace IDs, and span
IDs, and everything else.
And as you can see, every
time I do something,
it's going to try
to rebuild my app.
If you have tests, it
will run the tests.
And it will redeploy
this whole thing.
Now, the last piece of
this is that I really
want to also add
monitoring to this, right?
I want to be able to
see how many requests
is coming through.
How long do the requests take?
And the most important
thing in the JVM
is how much memory
I'm using in the heap.
And also, potentially, how
many threads am I running?
There are many ways
for you to get this.
If you have Prometheus,
you can write--
you can use a Prometheus agent.
Because I'm in Spring,
what I'm going to do
is to use what we call
the Micrometer, which
is another open-source
library that's out there.
So by adding Micrometer like
this with a Prometheus adapter,
in conjunction
with the actuator,
what this will do is to
potentially expose your matrix
onto an endpoint called
/actuator/prometheus.
And if you actually
have this configured,
then we can actually scrape
the Prometheus metrics
and automatically forward
that to Stackdriver Trace,
Stackdriver Monitoring as well.
And we can actually
graph and plot out
all of these different
metrics for you.
So this is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to go ahead and
just make sure that we
have the management.exposure.
Yeah, there we go.
So we want to expose the health
endpoint and the Prometheus
output here.
However, when you
do this, you've
got to be careful,
because now, anybody
who has access to
that load balancer
can actually hit these
endpoints, right?
So you're going
to see the health,
whether your application
is up or not.
You're going to see your
Prometheus stats and stuff
like that.
So you got to take care
of securing those URLs.
And you can do that
within the framework.
You can do that via
a proxy of some sort.
Or this is what I'm
going to do instead.
I'm going to go ahead
and put my actuator--
like this metadata information--
I'm going to put it
on a separate port.
I'm going to put it on
port 8081 instead, OK?
So I'm still serving my
application via port 8080.
My liveness check is
still on that port.
But then my readiness check,
my Prometheus information,
that's all going to be on the
internal port 8081 instead.
So we can definitely do
that right there, OK?
So let me go ahead and do that.
And then, of course, I
have to go back in here
and change out the
readiness probe to 8081.
If I want to use Prometheus
to scrape my application's
monitoring metrics, there
are a number of ways for you
to do it.
Mostly, you probably install
a Prometheus operator.
In my case, I just install
a bare minimum version
of Prometheus.
And then we added the
Stackdriver sidecar to it
so that we can automatically
forward the monitoring metrics
to Stackdriver Trace.
And for that to happen, I
do need to add a few more
annotations here.
So I'm going to
add an annotation.
And to tell Prometheus to
actually scrape my endpoints,
I'm going to say,
prometheus.io annotation scrape
is equal to true.
And I'm going to do
the similar thing here.
We need to know
which port to scrape.
So it's going to be
8081, because that's
where the endpoint is.
And then finally, I'm going to
do prometheus.io of path, which
is going to be actuator/path.
Oh, sorry, not that one--
like that, OK?
So again, I'm doing this in
the Skaffold development loop.
It's going to detect the
change in my deployment.
It's going to go ahead
and redeploy, now,
with the annotation, with
Prometheus scraping and all
that.
And we can see how this
whole thing kind of ties
up end to end.
And once my application
comes back up,
I should still be able
to access my app, right?
And then we should be able to go
ahead and go to the Monitoring
console to see what's
actually there.
So let's give it a try.
Oh, not like that.
So here we go.
So here's the endpoint
with the persons.
I'm going to go ahead and
say hello to all again.
So I'm going to say hello all.
And it's going to go
through this thing
with saying hello to
three people or so.
I can go back to my Trace.
And I'm going to
turn on auto reload.
And ideally, I should
be able to see the--
yeah, I can see my traces.
Now, this is actually happening
from Kubernetes cluster
with the logs outputted as JSON
and correlated to my Trace.
So everything works as expected
in my Kubernetes environment.
And for monitoring,
what I can do
is then go to Stackdriver
Monitoring, because I
have Prometheus all set up.
I can go to
Stackdriver Monitoring.
And I can hopefully
use my metrics export.
And I should be up to find
the metrics I want to see.
So here, we can go to Resources.
We can go ahead and--
there we go-- go to
the Metrics Explorer.
And I should be able to
see Kubernetes Container--
yeah, that one.
And then all of
these scraped metrics
is going to go into a metric
called external/prometheus--
Prometheus, yeah--
and then the suffix
of the actual metrics itself.
So for example, if I want
to see the server request--
so I can see request counts.
Where is it?
Right there.
And we can plot this
out from my application.
And I go-- so Group By, of
course, by the name of the pod.
And as you can see, I already
have some other application
running here.
You can see the metrics
from it, because the agent
is running right now.
We just need some time
for it to catch up, right?
The other thing that's also
very useful is the JVM metric.
So I'm going to say jvm_memory.
And we can see memory
used in that one.
That one's super useful.
And let me go ahead and group
by this by the name of the pod
and by name of the
container as well.
Now, you can already see--
you can already see that this is
definitely a Java application.
[LAUGHTER]
But why?
Because the heap is
going up, up, up.
And then there's
garbage collection.
And then you go up again.
But the good news
here is obviously
that there's no
memory leaks, right?
Because otherwise, you would
see this thing going up
all the time and eventually
get OOM killed, right?
So that's basically what you
can get from this whole thing.
Now, the last thing
I want to show you,
which is really, really awesome,
is by adding some debugging
agents into your application.
Now, what happens if you
are in a pinch, really,
really need to figure out
what happened to your app,
why is it not working, what
it is that we've done wrong,
you cannot reproduce
the issue locally.
You need to figure this out.
So we can actually go ahead
and add debugging agents
into this whole thing.
Now, we can go back
to the project.
This is where I'm going to go.
I'm going to go to source, main.
I'm going to create a
new directory here called
jib and agents, OK?
So anything you put into jib
will get into the container.
I'm going to go ahead
and copy my agents from--
let me see.
Where did I put it?
Desktop.
No, not that one.
Downloads, yeah, agents.
So I have a few agents here
I can copy into my directory.
So now I have--
when I'm building
my container, I
got these debugging
agents I can rely on
that can hook me up to
start debugging, even
from a Kubernetes environment.
But I do need to make sure
that when the application is
starting up, I do
have the right startup
flags to actually utilize the
agents that we just added.
So here, I'm going to add some
JVM flags, which will configure
the agents for me.
So I added two agents here.
I have a debugging agent, so I
can live-debug my application
live without stopping the world.
And I also added
a profiler agent,
so I can do
production profiling,
so I can kind of figure
out where the slowness is
kind of happening, right?
So let me go ahead
and save this.
And of course, Skaffold
is going to kick in again
and is going to rebuild this
application with, hopefully,
the debugging agents, with
an entry point with the agent
arguments that I passed in.
This is all very quick, that you
can see how this whole tool set
kind of ties up.
And then deploying it into my--
into Kubernetes cluster--
oh my goodness, yeah.
And we can see that
at the startup,
we can see the agent
actually kicked in.
So here's the output
from the agent.
And hopefully, my application
starts up fairly quickly.
Yeah, so it's all ready
to be used, I hope.
And then let's go and
see what we can do.
So I'm going to say--
let me just make sure I have
this thing all hooked up.
So I'm going to go to
persons, /persons, yeah.
Everything's still
working, good.
We only have five minutes left.
That's why I kept this
to the last, right?
If it doesn't work, then
thanks for being here.
All right, so--
[LAUGHTER]
So what we can do, then,
is-- this is so cool.
This is so cool.
If you've ever seen this
before, this is so cool.
So I'm going to go back
to my console here.
I'm going to go to debug.
So we saw Trace.
We saw Logging.
I'll tell you what.
I'm going to go to Profiler.
So because I added a
profiling agent there,
I can see my service
called demoservice,
which is the one I created.
I can see the version, which is
the one I put into the startup
command line.
And then I can see
the actual flame graph
of how much time, CPU
time, my application
is consuming at
different stages, right?
So I can click into it.
I can see the flame
chart underneath it.
So this is a really nice way
to kind of figure out where
all this time was being spent.
But here's the other thing that
you can do, which is debug.
This is super cool.
If you have your
code checking to git,
if you are using
the git plugins,
we can actually automatically
check out the code for you.
And we can automatically
find the source code, OK?
But in my case, because I
don't have the source code
uploaded, what that means
is that I need to somehow
wait for this UI to come
back up, in which case
I should be able to see my
service that's listed here.
Oh, thank goodness.
It still works.
All right.
So somehow, over here,
after some runtime,
I should be able to see
my application that I just
deployed.
I don't see it yet.
So we'll need to wait
a little bit for it
to come back up, right?
So let me just make sure
my app is still there.
Yeah, OK, good,
good, good, yeah.
So eventually,
this will come in.
And what I can do is to
browse through this UI,
hopefully find the application
I'm trying to debug.
And then, from there, I
can actually just start
adding these snapshot points.
Then I can capture the
state of my application
as the line's going
through the code.
And I don't know if this
ever happened to you.
When you're trying
to debug something,
and you see the log
messages, and then you say,
oh no, I wish I
have one more log--
[LAUGHTER]
--what do you do?
You got to go back,
check out the log,
check out the application,
check out the right revision
of the app, and then what?
And then check your backing,
go through the hot redeployment
of some sort, bypass a lot of
processes, and stuff like that.
I don't know.
It's trying to get to
production so you can actually
get that log message.
With a debugging agent, you
can actually do that directly
from the console, provided that
you do have the right access
to do that.
So let me see if this
actually came back.
Hopefully it's there.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
So now you can see that my
application registered itself
with the debugging console here.
So we can see demoservice
with the version 0.0.1.
I have no source code.
So I can go ahead and
upload it if I want to.
I can also do this from the
IDE as well, if I want to.
But right now, I'm just not go
ahead and upload my source code
in the Kotlin--
so this actually works with Java
and Kotlin right now, as well.
And then I'm going to go back
to this place right here.
I can see my source code.
And I can add a
snapshot point anywhere.
So I can say, I wonder what's
happening here-- again,
provided you have the
right permission to do it,
you can say, I wonder what is
happening on this line of code.
And then, if I come back
here, and if I say hello--
now, watch very carefully.
I'm going say name is
Ray again, I guess, Ray.
Watch carefully on the
right-hand side, hopefully.
Oh, well, somebody hit it first.
GreatTalk, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
That's awesome.
In case you don't want
those messages-- well,
I love this message.
But in case you don't want
to capture everything,
you can also add
conditions here, right?
So you can-- based
on the condition
of what you want to capture.
But thank you very
much for whoever
that send this first thing in.
So we can see the values.
You can also see the costack.
But so here's the thing.
Here's my favorite part
of this whole thing,
which is the logging part.
And somebody told me about this.
It's called binary
debugging with logs.
What does that mean?
This is what we
usually do, right?
We add a log message at first.
At the beginning, say, I'm here.
And then you add a message at
the very end to say, it works.
If it doesn't get to
"it works," that means
it broke somewhere
in the middle.
Then you add a message
in the middle somewhere.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe it broke here, right?
And every time you do this, we
actually output the log for you
into the log messages.
We should be able to
see it in the log here.
So if I do another refresh,
and when the logs come through,
we should be able to see
this being produced directly
in your production environment,
if you have the right process
and permission to do it, OK?
So with all that said, I think
we did a lot in the past 50
minutes.
Hopefully, it was very
useful for you, as well,
to kind of get a feel of what it
is like to develop applications
on Google Cloud with
framework support,
with all the tooling
that we have in the IDE,
in the plugins, and
with the other things,
like Skaffold and Jib.
If you want to learn more,
this is the last slide
I'm going to get to,
which is, we have quite
a few resources you can go to.
You can try a lot of things,
which I just showed you
in the Long Code lab.
If you want to learn more about
Spring and Spring Cloud GCP,
you can go to our
Short Code labs there.
We also have Coursera courses.
We got great, great
documentation.
And if you want to get
in contact with me,
you can find me on
Twitter or come to my site
and find more information.
So thank you so
much for being here.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]